environmentalists have dialed up their
publicity stunts in recent years
throwing soup on Priceless art gluing
themselves to buildings and shutting
down traffic even sometimes as people
are attempting to drive their children
to the hospital
all extremely stupid and Lawless stuff
which is presumably why Nevada tribal
Rangers decided to Ram through a group
of climate activists with a truck
[Applause]
you see the climate set up there
they've got all their signs
they're blocking the highway
the truck then Rams through it and then
turns around and comes back at the
activists
[Music]
the hippie is not not used to the tribal
Rangers
get on the ground
Rangers and pull their guns
and
those guns are not loaded with flowers
and pixie dust
this is not how ordinary police behave
this is not how you know the cops who
have their hands tied in New York or
Chicago or wherever behave now
but the tribal Rangers like the honey
badger do not appear to give
one little wit about their feelings so a
lot of people are cheering this on
and I understand the temptation to cheer
environmentalists are extremely annoying
but
context is key here as it is in all of
politics in this case what were the
environmentalists doing
they were attempting to shut down the
Burning Man festival that's what they
were protesting that those were the cars
they were stopping they were trying to
shut down the Burning Man festival which
is a week-long bacchanal of drugged out
hippies having orgies and worshiping a
fire idol in the middle of the desert so
in this case much as I hate to side with
the radical environmentalists
I guess I'm on their side here
Burning Man is bad
and people should shut it down
how did I end up on the side of these
weirdo hippies who are getting their
clocks knocked in on the Highway by the
Tribal Police politics makes for strange
bedfellows
so forget about burning man forget about
Nevada forget about the
environmentalists this is why
for instance many conservatives right
now are embracing Bobby Kennedy Jr
this is why never Trump lifelong
Republicans right now are embracing Joe
Biden and it is why conservatives are
going to have to rethink our tactics and
our alliances if we want to break out of
a pattern of perpetually losing I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show Oliver Anthony
the guy who went from a nobody to a big
star with that dobro guitar singing
about the rich man enrichment he just
came out to explain how angry he is that
conservatives like his music so we'll
we'll get to that in in just a moment
first though I don't want to move past
the environment too quickly
foreign
conservatives are right about everything
we're right about everything and when we
say things we're called idiots and Rubes
and ignoramuses and uneducated and and
then six months to two years later we're
proven right about every single thing in
this case
the stupid paper straws
everything we write about the covet vacs
we're right about the lockdowns we're
right about
human life and borders and the economy
and all of those issues but but even
down to the stupid paper straws do you
remember when a nine-year-old in Canada
had a school project where he called up
some straw companies and then
extrapolated the data data quote unquote
he got from a handful of straw companies
out to a whole nation and then made this
claim that we're wasting a bazillion
gazillion tons of plastic every minute
and then the liberal activists decided
to run with this little kid is the face
of environmentalism and then got all of
the restaurants to take away our straws
and force us to to drink our iced
coffees out of those paper things that
turn to just pulp and mush within three
sips
so you can't you just can't drink your
coffee remember when that happened over
the last five years well it turns out
the paper straws
are not safe for the environment
the whole reason we did that they they
are not better at bringing your drink
into your mouth
they're not more convenient they're not
cheaper they're not any of those things
the entire reason that we did it was
because a nine-year-old told us that the
plastic straws were bad for the
environment and that the paper straws
were good for the environment while the
paper straws are bad for the environment
new study shows that there are toxic
chemicals in there according to this
study the straws contain poly and per
fluoroalkyl substances
the FAS which are long lasting
potentially destructive to human health
but who cares about that and we've got
to prioritize the Delta smelt over human
beings these days they're also bad for
the environment according to Dr Timo
groffen
from the University of Antwerp straws
made from plant-based materials such as
paper and bamboo are often advertised as
being more sustainable and eco-friendly
but the pfas in there means that is not
necessarily the case they looked at 39
different straw bands and it turns out
that they're all pretty pretty bad for
the environment yeah of course
of course
this always happens we're always proven
right about these things and so here's
my recommendation I've made this
recommendation on the show before with
regard to totally different kinds of
issues my recommendation is
be normal
you should Endeavor at all times in your
life to be normal
this is true in your work it's true in
your
private life it's true in your
relationships it's true it's true even
in the straws you drink
buddy could conclude
that grinding up a bunch of industrial
made pulp and
upending the entire beverage industry in
five seconds is going to be good and
there was going to be no consequence to
that it's just crazy just be normal this
is the consequence of rationalism in
politics and people thinking that their
their own very small stock of reason
unfettered from tradition or Eternal
principles or anything else is
sufficient to remake Society into a
wonderful Utopia it never happens and
when it comes to the straws nobody
really cares it's a minor inconvenience
and maybe it's slightly bad for the
environment but again we were using
plastic before so who really cares but
but this can have
far more deleterious effect for human
beings as we're seeing in a very very
similar kind of study
with regard to the n95 masks that all of
the experts from the liberal
establishment including conservative
commentators told us to wear for years
turns out those aren't so great either
you know they say the eyes are the
window to the soul and the mouth which
was covered up by those masks is the
window to your stomach and the windows
are the windows to your house which is
why you got to check out Renewal by
Anderson right now text Knowles to 200
to 300 for most homeowners window
replacement is not something that
they've done before for many it is not
something they want to do but rather
something they have to do if you've put
off replacing the windows in your home
because it's too expensive I've got
great news for you you can call now to
get a free in-home window consultation
and a free price quote from Renewal by
Anderson Renewal by Anderson's signature
service is committed to giving you the
best customer experience possible
supported by the best people in the
industry the superior process and an
exclusive product someone just wrote
into my show the other day after hearing
me mention Renewal by Anderson and said
he's a carpenter and he said that when
he goes in and sees the work done by
Renewal by Anderson it is so far ahead
of the competition it's not even close
this guy was not it doesn't work for
Renewal by Anderson what the this wasn't
solicited he just wrote in because he
heard about it I have a cousin who works
for these guys from what I hear they are
just the absolute best in the business
so right now Renewal by Anderson is
offering a free in-home or virtual
consultation on durable quality
affordable windows or patio doors for
zero dollars down and zero payments zero
interest for one year text Knowles
Canada wlas to 200 300 for your free
consultation to save 375 bucks off every
window and 750 bucks off every door
these savings will not last long be sure
to check it out by texting Knowles to
200 300 that is Knolls to 200 300
texting privacy policy and terms and
conditions poster to textplan.us texting
enrolls for recurring automated text
marketing messages message and data
rates may apply reply stop to opt out go
to windowappointmentnow.com for full
offer details but the straws were bad
new study out shows that the n95 covid
masks
May expose wearers to dangerous levels
of compounds that are toxic and linked
to seizures
and cancer
initially we were told that the masks
just the stupid little hankies were
going to stop you from getting coveted
then the experts admitted that wasn't
true then we were told no no it's not
supposed to stop you from getting covid
those stupid masks are supposed to stop
you from spreading covid
then we found out that wasn't true then
we were told well no the hanky masks
that you were forced to wear for a while
they don't actually do anything but the
n95 masks those are the good ones
they're even conservatives got duped by
this
said well look we all know the hankies
don't do much but the n95 those are
great because some other expert told me
that
turns out no they had 95 masks
are not particularly effective at
stopping you from
catching covet or spreading covet and it
turns out they're bad for you they're
bad for your health
the surgical n95 mask which was the gold
standard has been proven to be Toxic by
researchers from jeon book National
University in South Korea
apparently the hanky masks are no good
either
you know I hate to say I told you so I
know a lot of you told people so with
regard to The Masks too though so the
question I have is
how did we know that
how did we
I don't have a particularly Advanced
degree I I barely got out of
12th grade science class had I don't I
don't know anything about masks I don't
know anything about viruses I'm not an
epidemiologist I don't have lots of
fancy degrees leggings detective energy
who's probably going to come back to
public life how is it that I and you and
your
hick ignoramus hillbilly Uncle Billy Bob
were all
much more correct about the scientific
questions than all the Geniuses with the
advanced degrees at the NIH how is that
the case
because
we know
that human beings were not made to
breathe into a big hunk of plastic or
cotton or any other kind of mask all the
time I think that's I think that's how
we knew it because we knew no matter
what the advertising said no matter what
the fauces said that human beings are
not supposed to do that that's not what
we're for that's not what our lungs are
for our lungs are not for
exhaling into a mask or inhaling through
some stupid mask we know that's not what
our faces are for we know our ears are
not for holding the mask fans on we just
know that's not normal
and because it's not normal
[Music]
there's a good shot it's going to have
some negative consequences for us that I
think that's that that was my thinking
at least
I didn't look at studies I think studies
are bogus I cite them when they back up
my point but I think most social science
and most surveys generally are are
claptrap and you have your statistics
and I have my statistics and 152 percent
of Statistics are made up
but we at the very least know ordinary
normal people
with even a modicum of Common Sense
no
that human beings are not supposed to
act like weirdos all the time
and the libs just incessantly try to get
us to act like weirdos
as a matter of public health in our
schools in our jobs
certainly in our sex lives they're
always pushing that
and it's just
if you have any common sense you know
it's just it's probably not good this
was a point that Santana just made
the the rock star Santana got in big
trouble
I'm so late to this story I'm glad I'm
late to this story because there was the
first headline and then because we
didn't report on the first headline then
we already got the inevitable
backtracking so now we just get the full
story all at once Santana
made headlines for his shocking
unhinged rant someone reported this as
crazy rant
that
[Music]
and this gets back to something we've
I've been bringing up on the show a
little bit more recently because it's it
used to be the basic understanding of
virtue that now people are not only
ignorant of I think they don't even
think it's possible and it's this notion
Aristotle talks about it in the nick of
Mickey and ethics famously which is
there are four kinds of people when it
comes to Virtue they're the
self-indulgent who do bad things and
they love doing bad things
they're the incontinent who do bad
things but they know they should do good
things there are the continent who do
good things and they know they should do
good things but it's a real struggle and
they really they want to eat more than
more to Dell than they should maybe I'm
somewhere around there hopefully but
then there's actually another category
and these are the people who are truly
happy who have achieved what Aristotle
would call you daimonia and those are
the people who enjoy doing virtuous
things
and so that's what you really want you
can't have a society as liberalism
classical in modern tells us we can of
just pragmatic Solutions all the time to
constantly competing ideas and and of
the good and the true and the Beautiful
and of personal interest where we just
have these pragmatic Solutions and we
leave everybody alone and we remain
totally skeptical about ultimate truths
you you can't really do that okay you've
got you have to have a society in which
the the people are cultivating the right
kind of desires
and and and
uniting their actions with their desires
and uniting their their actions and
their desires with the use of right
reason this sounds also mamby pambi Pie
in the Sky I know this is how society's
operated
for like all of human history
to some degree or another reached its
flourishing in the West in what we used
to call Christendom and it's totally
cracked up in liberalism
and it's taking a political philosopher
like Santana to point us back in the
right direction we got to talk about
these things whether you're on stage
with Santana or whether you're sitting
at home with your Pure Talk cell phone
right now go to puretalk.com Knowles is
your cell phone in desperate need of
replacement you know the signs short
battery life so you've got to have a
charger on hand cracked screen that
gives you a little glass splinters well
it's time to put that old phone to rest
and upgrade to a new 5G Samsung Galaxy
from Pure Talk for free get a free 5G
Samsung Galaxy with two day battery life
edge to edge display and Ultra strong
Gorilla Glass when you sign up for Pure
talks unlimited talk text and 15 gig
data plan for just 35 bucks a month plus
it comes with a mobile hotspot if you
are not using puretalk you are simply
paying too much get all the data you
could ever need for half the price of
the big carriers on America's Most
Dependable 5G Network go to puretalk.com
Knowles kwles for your free super
durable 5G Samsung Galaxy when you
switch to Pure Talk that is puretalk.com
Knowles then make the switch to my cell
phone company that would be Pure Talk
the official Wireless partner of the
daily wire
when Dr Jordan B Peterson made the
decision to join daily wire plus it was
a major win for those who Champion
intellectual debate with one year of
unparalleled output his contributions
have set new standards and remained
unmatched by any other platform the
lower plus now has a vast array of
exclusive Jordan Peterson content
offering hundreds of hours of
captivating content you won't find
anywhere else Jordan has created thought
provoking works that reshape your
perspective on life which include vision
and Destiny marriage and Dragons
monsters and men the way that the commas
and the ands work in Jordan's shows they
all blur together I don't know which is
which but they're all terrific
Additionally you can immerse yourself in
discussions that nurture your spiritual
side like logos and literacy and
Jordan's groundbreaking series on the
book of Exodus that is only the
beginning
I've not even mentioned his Beyond order
lecture well I guess I just did mention
that that's great that lecture series is
terrific his extensive Archive of
lectures and podcasts this is the
compendium of all things Jordan plus
there's even more new exclusive content
on the horizon this is only the
beginning by becoming a daily wire plus
member you will embark on an
unforgettable experience that will fuel
your thirst for knowledge and Inspire
personal growth like never before go to
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member today
speaking of conservatism in the Public
Square
Nothing Gold Can Stay
nothing even with gold hued redheaded
beards like Oliver Anthony
can stay
conservatives loved Oliver Anthony he's
the guy with the dobro guitar in the
woods with the very slick high
production quality music video that was
presented as a creedecurer from a guy
with a Handycam in the middle of the
woods and he sang about the rich man
north of Richmond close to near run and
the conservatives rallied around him and
made him the biggest star in the country
and then
now Oliver Anthony is irritated by that
and he doesn't want conservatives
claiming his music
it's aggravating seeing people on
conservative news try to identify with
me like I'm one of them
it's aggravating seeing certain
musicians and politicians act like we're
buddies and and act like we're fighting
the same struggle here like that we're
trying to present the same message
you know I've had a lot of people reach
out to me and I tried to be polite to
everybody and um I've talked to hundreds
of people the last two weeks but it
seems like certain people want to just
ride the attention of the song that
maybe make them their own selves
relevant and that's aggravating as hell
the other thing that I find aggravating
is uh
well you know like it was funny seeing
my song in the
it was fun it was funny seeing it the
presidential debate
because it's like I wrote that song
about those people you know so for them
to have to sit there and listen to that
uh that cracks me up
uh but it was funny kind of seeing the
response to it like that song has
nothing to do with Joe Biden you know
it's a lot bigger than Joe Biden
um
that song is written about the people on
the on that stage and a lot more too not
just them but but definitely them
all right little little incoherent here
this is what I pointed out about Oliver
Anthony's Song which I I thought showed
clear Talent he's obviously a pretty
talented folksy artist but the lyrics
didn't make a ton of sense because they
melded new populist impulses
with
kind of generic establishment Chamber of
Commerce GOP complaints about welfare
queens and things like that so I said
the lyrics aren't totally coherent but
as far as a first shot goes musically he
said he at least has a good voice the
the whole character and Persona works
pretty well no wonder that the the video
went viral now he's saying look this
song this has nothing to do with Joe
Biden it's it's about much more than Joe
Biden well hold on which is again this
is contradictory is does it have nothing
to do with Joe Biden or is it about Joe
Biden and the whole political system
well he seems to be
saying both things at once but but he's
really focused on Republicans he's
saying no it's the guys on the
Republican debate stage that I was
singing about they're the ones that I'm
complaining about not Joe Biden it's the
Republicans and there's some evidence
that the guy is a Democrat he there was
some Facebook post I saw going around I
think it was authentic in which he was
complimenting Joe Biden there's a video
of him uh just mumbling through the
classic liberal platitudes about you
know the truth this true strength of
America is our diversity
I mean we are the Melting Pot of the
world and that that's what makes us
strong is our diversity and we need to
learn to harness that and appreciate it
and not use it as a political tool to
keep everyone separate from each other
you know so that that kind of a
statement I mean we all like people of
different cultures and things like that
but the statement diversity is our
strength that is a very modern extremely
liberal slogan that is used to justify
Mass migration and to displace and to
injure the very working class that this
guy is supposedly singing about he then
tweets out he says I don't support
either side politically not the left not
the right I'm about supporting people
and restoring local communities now go
breathe some fresh air and relax please
I'm not worth obsessing over I promise
go spend times with your Loved Someone
okay I'm not gonna be too harsh on
Oliver Anthony because I think what he's
doing here is probably smart
Oliver Anthony doesn't want to be
ghettoized into the conservative media
sphere where he becomes you know the
favorite folksy singer of a handful of
shows like this show this show maybe a
few other podcasts maybe a couple shows
on Fox News and that's it that's going
to be his career no he he wants to be
mainstream he's gotten a taste of Fame
and money and he he wants to be a real
player who can sell out stadia and go on
all sorts of other shows so okay fine
what's my
suspicion here
I don't think that Oliver Anthony has
any particular
political philosophy or ideology
I don't think that Oliver Anthony just
one day accidentally stumbled on Fame I
don't think he walked out into the woods
with his dogs in this dobro and just set
up a little camcorder and then just
accidentally went viral I think this is
a guy who's been a struggling songwriter
for a long time who
saw his opportunity and made a bet on a
very slickly produced music video and
made the right kind of connections so
that the video could go viral and he
prepared to meet the opportunity that
came along and that opportunity came
along because of a specific moment in
our culture
that's the key
I don't think this guy has changed
popular music or popular art I think
this guy saw which way the wind was
blowing and he took his opportunity this
happens all the time in movies this
happens all the time in music
you have one
hit
you get one little hint oh our war
movies are in now okay then you're gonna
get a lot of war movies this particular
brand of pop music is in okay this one
band does really where you're going to
get a whole bunch of other
Pretenders who who try to copy that act
and I think here since especially since
the election of Donald Trump
especially since the rise of populism
nationalism here in Britain in Europe
this has been building for some years
now
this guy saw okay this is the moment for
a Creed occur about the Forgotten men
and women of America you saw the success
of JD Vance's book hillbilly allergy
turned into a big movie One JD a senate
seat
it's it's not as though the signs
weren't there and this guy met his
moment so this is why I really like the
Oliver Anthony phenomenon
I don't have any particular interest in
Oliver Anthony or even in his song
but I do like that a guy who was
prepared to meet opportunity at a pretty
sharp Observer of culture
saw that the culture is moving in a
direction that is very favorable to us
now maybe the ruling class will just
clamp down on that and continue to rig
the elections and continue to censor
conservatives and continue to
incentivize even the people who become
famous as conservatives to to disavow
all of us and everything we believe
maybe that'll happen maybe the Liberals
just have too much power but the wind is
blowing in our Direction no question
about it
now speaking of the culture
that Russian paramilitary leader
pregosian who led the aborted coup on on
Vladimir Putin and then was given safe
passage to Belarus and then accidentally
his plane was shot out of the sky it was
unclear if he was dead or not did he
fake his own death do you sneak out on
another plane well Russian authorities
have confirmed through DNA analysis he
was on the plane
they got him they got him and so the
Saturday essay in the Wall Street
Journal
was on The Godfather in the Kremlin it
was a picture of Putin dressed like Don
Corleone
says the very public death of Putin
henchman yevgeny pregosian highlights
the evolution of Russia into a mafia
state held together by violence and
incapable of Global Leadership
it's a long essay I'm not going to read
any of it the headline and the sub
headlines suffice
does that sound familiar to you
does that sound familiar
a
a country being transformed into a mafia
state
held together by violence and incapable
of Global Leadership I know it's been a
little while since our political Elites
encouraged street thugs to burn the
country down Coast to Coast for eight
months
that was what that was about three years
ago wasn't that long ago
and our ruling class is currently
jailing political dissidents
for nothing other than simply opposing
the regime I'm not even forget about the
January six people let's pretend for a
moment that cracking a Coors Light in
the capital rotunda were a capital
offense forget about them for a second
but Douglas Mackey Douglas Mackey is a
guy who didn't even have that many
followers on Twitter who posted some
funny memes about the 2016 election he
faces 10 years in prison
because the memes were pro-trump and
anti-hillary
what about Donald Trump himself who
faces 750 years in prison for
questioning the rigged election that's
it that's all he did he just said hey I
think this election that you all rigged
I think it might have been a little
rigged
how about Trump's lawyers and supporters
who did nothing but provide the man a
legal counsel
who did nothing but fulfilled their most
basic Duty as lawyers being thrown in
prison
does that sound like a little bit I hate
look I hate to say it about my own
country does that sound a little bit
like a mafia state
like a little bit like a Banana Republic
where we're now jailing the political
opposite leader of the opposition and
the former president incapable of Global
Leadership
a country that under Joe Biden
will he will they won't they pull out of
Afghanistan complete collapse will they
won't they invite Vladimir Putin to
invade Ukraine happened now we're on the
precipice of this drawn out introduction
potentially to World War III will they
won't let they allowed Xi Jinping to
invade Taiwan
will they want they incapable of Global
Leadership
is that Drew makes this point all the
time and it's important I mean this is
the big debate between on that stage
between the primary candidates you had a
Mike Pence who was giving his morning in
America routine everything's great we
just need to feel good about ourselves
again and Vivek ramaswamy saying no
everything's not great this is a dark
moment in the country and if we want to
fix it I think we can fix it but we got
to acknowledge it
at least on that question I think Vivek
has got it right
I hate to say it about my own country
but but Drew Clavin points this out a
lot he says the problem with bigots
is not that they're wrong about the
other guy
bigots you know people who really hate
people on the basis of their race or
they're this or that it's not that
they're wrong about the other guy
because there are flaws with all sorts
of people
the issue with bigots is that they're
wrong about themselves
it's not that their opinion is too low
of the other guy said their opinion is
too high of themselves and I think
that's our issue here I'm not saying
that Putin's not a mob boss sure puts a
mob boss
but we don't have a lot of credibility
to call him out for that or any of our
other Geo political adversaries
if we ourselves are behaving like the
mob which is what's happening
my favorite comment yesterday is from
John Apple 3471 who says
the real question is how would people
react
if Trump does formally prove that the
2020 election was stolen
they would react exactly as they're
reacting now which is that his
supporters would be irate and upset and
offended
and the Liberals would shrug their
shoulders you know how I know this
forget about the elections fraud claims
we have
pretty much as much evidence as we could
have that Joe Biden peddled American
influence for multi-million dollar
bribes from every crooked leader on
planet Earth
okay we have text messages we have
emails we have handwritten notes we have
investigations we have we we can track
the money
we got it all we've got the we've got
the the prosecutors in the countries
that bribe Joe Biden saying yes they
were bribing the bidens we've got it all
and people don't care it doesn't matter
the Biden people support Biden the libs
support Joe Biden
and many of the conservatives support
Trump
some of the conservatives hate Trump and
they're either going to try to find
another guy
or they're going to be the never Trump
people and go over to Biden they're
going to say well I endorse the liberal
establishment even against Donald Trump
because I I hate him so much or
something
that's what's going to happen that is
happening right now
doesn't matter you could put us you
could have
the smoking guns smoking right up their
nostrils would not change
a thing
speaking of foreigners
Karen Bass
it's the mayor of Los Angeles now Karen
bass is a former member of Congress she
is a communist she actually worked for
many years with communist organizations
like I don't call liberals Communists a
lot I know some people on the right do
that this woman actually is a communist
she is about as bad a mayor as you could
possibly imagine in City of Angels and
she is now complaining
because Texas has sent some buses of
illegal aliens up to California up to
Los Angeles and Karen bass has said
La has not extended an invitation asking
for people to come this is a political
Act
la which for many years now has built
itself as a sanctuary state has
according to the mayor of La not invited
the immigrants to come
of course it has I don't want to ascribe
to malice that which is explained by
ignorance maybe Karen bass doesn't
understand the basic meaning of words
but when when you say we're a state that
offers Sanctuary to you people that is
an invitation to the people to come Los
Angeles just didn't expect that to
happen it's very easy for these blue
states to in blue cities
to say that they're totally open to
illegal aliens when it's the red States
and the red places that have to deal
with the brunt of the illegal
immigration so okay total hypocrisy
fine
here too though forget about the
immigration issue the fact that our
political leaders will look Us in the
face and say hey that word that word
doesn't mean what that word means that's
much more distressing that's more
distressing than 10 million illegal
aliens coming into the country
the fact that they will look Us in the
face
and they do it with a whole lot of words
you know I'm not allowed to say
how they do this with regard to
bathrooms and things like that on
YouTube but they'll do that
I'll just say it they'll look Us in the
face and say that men are women and
women are men they look Us in the face
and say that foreigners are American
citizens they'll look Us in the face and
say Sanctuary doesn't mean sanctuary
I mean stay away you Arie what do you
well at that point
the political order breaks down
if you can't if you can't even agree on
the basic meaning of words then the
political order breaks down and politics
ceases to be a matter of rational debate
and deliberation and becomes a matter of
brute grunting Force like we're a bunch
of Apes running around
Purple Mountain majesties from sea to
shiny sea
now speaking of people
that no one invited
there's this group called No Labels
they've they've started about 10 years
ago
and it's a group
of fashionable Centrist liberals who say
we need we don't need these crazies on
the right and we don't need these
crazies on the left we just need
sensible tax cutting socially liberal
establishment types and then
if we only run candidates who are
exactly like Bill Clinton then will have
a flourishing country
and will will all of the rancor and
division will go away so Joe Lieberman
who's one of these figures he was
considered a potential running mate to
John McCain even though he was a
Democrat Senator he was considered a
potentially the Republican vice
presidential candidate in 2008 he is the
chairman of No Labels and he says no
labels it's going to hold a nominating
convention for 2024. No Labels is is
challenging the political status quo and
and in a way the control that the two
parties have over our uh political
system we think uh there's a real
opportunity for a third choice and that
it's the American people are telling us
on polling we're doing in discussions
we're having that
they've lost confidence in the two major
parties and by large numbers they don't
want to have to choose again between
President Trump and President Biden we
already have scheduled a bipartisan
convention think about it we haven't
seen that ever in my recent history a
bipartisan nominating convention for
Dallas Texas in April of next year
this is not going to work this is not
going to work I mean it could be funny
I'm all for more uh Madness and Chaos in
this presidential race I'm more I'm all
for throwing wrenches into the system so
it could be fun if they nominated Joe
manchin or something that guy's not
going to become president the reason
it's not going to work is because Joe
Lieberman is right that the two
candidates who are the presumptive
nominees of their parties
are historically unpopular and it is
true that many people indicate that they
don't want to vote for those nominees
the the reason for that though is not so
much the particular candidates yes Joe
Biden looks kind of sleepy yes Donald
Trump is off-putting to certain people
but the reason for that is because of
polarization
you're seeing that unpopularity among
the candidates because of people in the
opposite parties that's really what's
driving it
because the libs are becoming more lib
and the conservatives are becoming more
conservative
and so as they become as the
conservatives become more conservative
the Liberals are going to hate them even
more and vice versa
so you're not going to solve that
problem by nominating a supposed
Centrist
because that's the constituency that is
most getting squeezed
as the as the groups are becoming more
coherently and clearly what they are
they're following their ideas for their
logical conclusions then the group
that's disappearing are these Centrist
liberals to say No Labels is a misnomer
it's a false label too
it's a it's the central lie of
liberalism which is that you can have
political neutrality there's no such
thing as neutrality in politics you're
going to think something is good you're
going to think something is bad you're
going to say some things are true and
some things are false so there is no
neutrality what no labels is proposing
is just going back to the 1990s what no
labels is proposing is that we all vote
for candidates like Bill Clinton and
Tony Blair
because they say that those candidates
they're they're above politics they're
they're they they're reasonable they're
in the middle no they're not they're
just another kind of label they're
clintonites call them clintonites call
them new Democrats new labor whatever
that's what it is 1990s call it a time
machine
there's there's no way to escape a label
this is even I think about it even with
our side you know a lot of conservatives
a lot of my friends a lot of my
Protestant friends will say that they're
non-denominational Protestants and
I find this to be a funny label because
as so many of them repeat this they say
I am a non-denominational Protestant I I
think that the the word starts with a
capital N or he has a capital D
I think there's a trademark sign over
the end of that phrase because
if you identify as non-denominational
and if you group yourself with other
people who call themselves
non-denominational then you have become
a denomination
not knocking it one way or the other I'm
just saying it obviously is some people
are Methodist some people are
Episcopalian some people are
non-denominational but those are all
denominations
some people are Republican some people
are Democrats some people say they're no
labels well you can call yourself it's
capital n capital L it's no labels and
it means
a 90s style
of fiscally somewhat responsible
socially uh decadent or permissive kind
of
Clinton type that's what it is
and the one thing I can promise you
politically who knows what's going to
happen in this election we don't know
you can't predict the future
but it it ain't the 90s anymore man
in it and people have a sort of
nostalgia just like people in the 1970s
conservatives in the 70s had a Nostalgia
for the 50s
well similarly now that's why you had
Happy Days and and sitcoms like that
similarly now people have a Nostalgia
for the 90s we say things were so good
in the 90s
no the seeds of the madness that we've
got going on today
economic political sexual artistic all
of it uh he was there in the 90s and
those ideas followed to their logical
conclusion and if we rewind the clock we
would almost certainly end up in the
same place we are again today
people are realizing
through history that there are some
problems with the things that we thought
them
and so whoever wins in 2024 whatever the
political landscape looks like moving
forward
it's not going to be a carbon copy of
how things were 25 years ago we are in
uncharted waters they have arrested the
leader of the political opposition
whatever prediction you think that
you've got about 2024
I would take a step back and a little
dose of humility and gird yourself for
the unexpected things that could come
now today is a very special day
and I've promised producer Danny
but I'm going to try to make his life
easier by not requiring him to deal with
the crazy edit where they've gotta
they've got to accommodate the YouTube
sensors on because I can't say it's
Tuesday it's a word that's alliterative
with Tuesday it's something I can't talk
about on YouTube because I can talk
about in the member block
and the Inner Circle so I
it's like when a certain sex thinks that
okay
it's
Tuesday the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
and also check out for two months free
on all annual plans
we'll see you over there
[Music]